well i'm joined now by uh talk tv
presenter richard tice and royal author
extraordinaire tina brown i can't think
of anybody i'd rather have the new team
to wrap up this extraordinary period in
british history actually and great to
see you richard you've been here pretty
much ever present uh from the start and
it has been truly fascinating time i
think and we'll look back on it and
we'll all remember where we were when
the queen died and when these
extraordinary events rolled out
what do you make of it where are we with
all this well you know i felt coming as
i do now from new york it's like it was
like the queen's last great act of soft
power from dying in scotland which
reminded them of wanting to be at the
heart of the union perhaps again
to this last extraordinary uh these days
where these this crowd came together in
this incredibly beautiful way so
actually the crowd became as much of the
event as as the actual funeral became it
was i mean what struck me i've written a
column about this for the sun tonight
was that
all the flash points of division
between us in this country going back to
brexit whether it's donald trump brexit
covet vaccines you know independence in
scotland the northern ireland protocol
is a result of brexit being threatened
and so on all these issues which really
had split families apart i know people
who literally fell out with family
members over some of these issues they
split up friendship groups they turned
us into a sort of toxic society fueled
by social media people taking sides on
everything screaming at each other and
then we just had this gigantic pause
well none of that mattered i don't think
anybody in these huge crowds probably
had any discussion about any of those
things it was all centered on on one
thing which was our monarch our monarchy
and the national identity of our country
absolutely and also those incredible uh
the traditions the richness of our
history
was dramatized before our very eyes and
and suddenly you saw what charles was
king of
so from his point of view you know the
last year he has actually been the
stand-in for his ailing mother and all
of a sudden
he has he has stepped into the void left
by her and you know i thought my biggest
concern before it happened was that the
country would just spin you know in this
sense of unbelievable loss which it has
but there has also been a reassurance
from it because you saw the great thick
sort of you know the richness of these
traditions that really have this potency
and into that void stepped charles i
mean you wrote this i mean incredibly
pressing but the palace papers inside
the house of windsor the truth and the
turmoil on the back can the monarchy
survive
um that question has been answered i
think this week i think it's been
answered i think king charles i mean
richard we've been talking about it a
lot but i think king charles iii has got
off to an extraordinarily strong start
in reassuring us as tina said that he
has what it takes to follow his mother
completely because what he did actually
appears he gripped it literally the
moment it happened and he reassured uh
and gave confidence to the nation and in
a sense
he's proven that
the monarchy is it's our constant it's
our foundation one of the key
foundations of the united kingdom and
he's proven that actually it can survive
anything and we've celebrated and in a
sense yesterday
the life of the greatest britain in my
view and we're all privileged to be part
of that history and interestingly tina i
think that she had the same kind of
philosophy
about how to deal with challenges as the
greats of winston churchill who was her
first prime minister and i suspect the
one that she had the most respect for uh
but his one was kbo keep buggering on uh
through world war ii of course
and her version of that as we heard from
jacinda ardern the new zealand prime
minister when she said how did you have
children and be reigning a country i
can't imagine she said well you just get
on with it and actually i love that but
that is so exactly right and of course
prince philip always used to say look up
look out
say less do more and i love that
philosophy and that was of course the
queen's philosophy all the languages
never complain never explain don't give
interviews don't show too much of your
own self you don't need to and actually
the less they showed her and her mother
the queen mother and all the queen
mother ever had to do was stay in london
during the blitz and not leave to safety
she could have done and then go down to
the east end and stand in the rubble and
say i'm here for you and the public
never ever forgot that they loved her
from that moment i think i think very
similar to that was the sort of wordless
rebuke if you like of the way the queen
sat alone
obeying the coveted rules you know in
that winston you know in windsor
traveling the rules of the people who
were setting them the night before
correct were breaking with two illicit
parties at number 10 and there's
something about the juxtaposition of
those facts i think when when people
read about the downing street parties
they remembered the queen sitting there
alone and it was such i think that's
finished off boris johnson actually i
think he would have survived partygate
hadn't been for the harrowing image of a
lonely queen mourning the rock of her
life because she felt a duty to obey the
rules the person who'd made them and his
team would break him with such and she
couldn't visit him for six weeks in
hospital yeah the agony of that for her
because they never thought of jumping
the kids probably could have jumped the
queue and we'll come to that later but
we could have done she's the queen but
she decided she would never do what her
people weren't allowed to do it
reinforced the difference between a
monarchy the queen and the duke of
edinburgh they always delivered they
performed they performed they just got
on with it they rolled their sleeves up
they worked hard and hard and hard and
it was never in doubt and i think i
think that's what king charles will now
show us he's been out there he's been
meeting people he's been visible and i
think we should actually be full of
confidence